5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND THIS
IS "THE FIVE"."
MOMENTS FROM NOW THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE WILL BE
COMING OUT FOR A ANOTHER
BRIEFING, WE WILL TAKE YOU THERE
WHEN IT HAPPENS.
BUT FIRST, THE OTHER BIG NEWS,
BARACK OBAMA FINALLY ENDORSES
JOE BIDEN.
FOR MONTHS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SAT ON THE SIDELINES AND STAYED
SILENT WATCHING HIS VP GET
PUMMELED IN AN ABSOLUTELY BRUTAL
PRIMARY SEASON.
BUT NOW THAT BIDEN HAS BEEN
VICTORIOUS, THINGS HAVE CHANGED
ANY MAJOR WAY.
>> HONESTY AND HUMILITY HAD
EMPATHY AND GRACE, THAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP DOES NOT JUST BELONG
IN OUR STATE CAPITALS AND MAYOR
OFFICES, IT BELONGS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND THAT’S WHY I AM SO PROUD TO
ENDORSE JOE BIDEN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
CHOOSING JOE TO BE MY
VICE PRESIDENT WAS ONE OF THE
BEST DECISIONS I EVER MADE.
AND HE BECAME A CLOSE FRIEND.
AND I BELIEVE THAT JOE HAS ALL
THE QUALITIES WE NEED ANY
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: SO WHY DID IT TAKE
SO LONG?
REMEMBER, IT HAS BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED THAT BIDEN WAS NOT
OBAMA’S FIRST CHOICE.
HE TRIED TO GET BIDEN NOT TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
WORRIED THAT HIS FORMER VP WOULD
"EMBARRASS HIMSELF."
MEANWHILE JOE BIDEN DESPERATELY
NEEDS THE SUPPORT OF
BERNIE SANDERS FAR LEFT
SUPPORTERS.
SANDERS OWN CAMPAIGN SPOKESWOMAN
OPENLY ATTACKED BIDEN AND
REFUSED TO ENDORSE.
SO LISTEN TO OBAMA’S PITCH TO
THOSE DISAFFECTED BERNIE
SUPPORTERS.
>> IF I WAS RUNNING TODAY, I
WOULD NOT RUN THE SAME RACE OR
HAVE THE SAME PLATFORM AS I DID
IN 2008.
TO THE WORLD IS DIFFERENT, THERE
IS TOO MUCH UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FOR US TO JUST LOOK BACKWARDS.
WE HAVE TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
BERNIE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
ANGELO UNDERSTANDS THAT.
IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
JOE ALREADY HAS WHAT IS THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE PLATFORM OF ANY
MAJOR PARTY NOMINEE IN HISTORY.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT,
JUDGE JEANINE, THE THING THAT
STRUCK ME WAS HOW GREAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IS UP TOP.
I GUESS THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
ENDORSEMENT?
I KNOW YOU CAN’T DO IT IN FRONT
OF A 30,000 CROWD IN A SWING
STATE.
IT IS A PITCH ON THE INTERNET,
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> Judge Jeanine: I THINK IT
IS DISINGENUOUS AT BEST.
A LOT OF WHAT HE SAID DOES NOT
REALLY HOLD ANY WATER.
WHAT DOES HOLD WATER IS GAGGED,
HE IS PROBABLY MORE PROGRESSIVE,
BUT MOST OF THE PROGRESSIVES
INCLUDING THE SANDERS PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO DISAGREE, BECAUSE THEY
WANT MEDICARE FOR ALL.
THEY WANT THEIR STUDENT DEBT
ELIMINATED, AND THEY WANT A
WEALTH TAX.
AND JOE BIDEN IS NOT IN FAVOR OF
ANY OF THAT.
BUT I CAN’T HELP BUT THINK, AND
MAYBE IT IS JUST THE SKEPTIC IN
ME, BUT I SAY TO MYSELF, WHO IS
JOE BIDEN?
WHY DOES OBAMA WANT TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS?
THINK ABOUT IT, JESSE.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU
REMEMBER A PRESIDENT, AN
EX-PRESIDENT ACTIVELY
CAMPAIGNING AGAINST A SITTING
PRESIDENT?
THIS IS CONTRARY TO ANYTHING WE
HAVE SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY
BEFORE.
BUT BARACK OBAMA HATES
DONALD TRUMP SO MUCH THAT HE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GO AFTER
HIM.
AND IT DOES NOT MATTER WHETHER
IT IS AN EMPTY SUIT LEG
JOE BIDEN OR A GUY WHO DOES NOT
KNOW WHERE HE IS OR WHAT HE IS
THINKING.
MAYBE THEY HAVE PEOPLE AROUND
THEM WHO WILL CONTROL JOE, AND
MAYBE THAT’S TO OBAMA’S BENEFIT.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE FACT
THAT WE ARE JUST HEARING FROM
OBAMA DOES NOT MEAN THAT HE JUST
SHOWED UP.
HE HAS BEEN IN THE BACKGROUND
THE WHOLE TIME PULLING STRINGS.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE DEFINITELY
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
I’M WONDERING TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT FORMER PRESIDENTS, DANA,
GETTING OUT THERE FOUR YEARS
LATER AND CAMPAIGNING AGAINST
INCUMBENTS.
DID BILL CLINTON GET OUT THERE
IN 2004 AND GO AFTER BUSH?
FROM WHAT I REMEMBER, HE LAID
PRETTY LOW.
>> Dana: I’M TRYING TO
REMEMBER, AND I DON’T THINK THAT
HE DID.
AND ALSO I THINK IN 2012, I’M
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT THAT AS
THE JUDGE WAS SAYING THAT.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT 43 DID
ANYTHING BEYOND CONGRESSIONAL
INCENTIVE RACES.
SO YES, THAT PROBABLY HOLDS
TRUE.
I’VE BEEN TELLING YOU FROM THE
BEGINNING, JESSE, WHEN EVERYBODY
WAS VOTING OBAMA, WHY WON’T YOU
DO IT?
I SAID THAT HE WILL NOT DO IT
THAT IT IS SECURED.
AND I THINK IT IS A LITTLE BIT
LIKE A SUGAR HIGH, BECAUSE NOW
THAT HE HAS DONE IT AND WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC, I
DON’T THINK THAT IT WILL HAVE A
LOT OF LONG-TERM ENERGY.
HE DID NOT INCLUDE A
FUND-RAISING LINK IN THE VIDEO,
WHICH I THINK THE MADURO REALLY
NEEDS.
USUALLY I WOULD BE DISMISSIVE OF
WHAT FORMER CAMPAIGN AIDES SAID
ABOUT SOMETHING, BUT THE
BERNIE SANDERS CAMPAIGN PEOPLE,
THEY HAVE QUITE A LARGE
SOCIAL MEDIA FALLING, AND THEY
ARE NOT BUYING IT, JUST BECAUSE
BERNIE CAVES, THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO CAVE.
THERE IS A LOT TO BE DECIDED.
AND WHO KNOWS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC HOW PRESIDENT OBAMA
COULD BE EFFECTIVE?
I DO THINK HE HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE.
AND WHEN THE HISTORY BOOKS ARE
BRITAIN, WHEN BERNIE WON IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, WE WILL FIND OUT
THAT BARACK OBAMA HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF SOMETHING TO NUDGE THAT
ENDORSEMENT IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FROM CONGRESSMAN.
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU ARE
PROBABLY RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
JUAN, CAN YOU TRANSLATE WHAT HE
MEANT WHEN HE WAS MAKING THE
PITCH TO THE BERNIE BROS, WHAT
WAS HE SELLING THERE?
>> Juan: HE WAS SAYING YOU
HAVE A MORE AGGRESSIVE CANDIDATE
AND JOE BIDEN THEN HE WAS WHEN
HE RAN AN ’08 AND UP ’12, AND
EVEN WHEN HE LEFT OFFICE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTED THE
PRESIDENT TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE
WITH REGARDS TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE, THINGS LIKE HOW DO WE
PAY FOR COLLEGE?
BUT THE LARGER POINT, AGAIN,
SPEAKING TO WHAT JUDGE JEANINE
MENTIONED, REMEMBER THAT
BILL CLINTON HAD A LITTLE
PROBLEM THAT WAS NOT EXACTLY
HELPFUL TO AL GORE.
AND PRESIDENT BUSH HAD THE WAR,
WHICH WAS NOT POPULAR.
AND IT WAS NOT GOING TO BE
HELPFUL TO JOHN McCAIN.
IT IS A DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE A CANDIDATE,
JOE BIDEN WHO HAS DEFIED ALL THE
DOUBTERS AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
CALLED HIM NAMES, AND HE HAS
BEAT ALL OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND NOW WE
HAVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THE
MOST POPULAR DEMOCRAT IN THE
COUNTRY, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
RIDING SHOTGUN.
AND COULD NOT HAVE ANY ONE
BETTER, JOE BIDEN KNOWS
BARACK OBAMA, BARACK OBAMA KNOWS
JOE BIDEN.
HE CAN SPEAK TO HIS CHARACTER
ABOUT THE EMPATHY AND KINDNESS
THAT WE SEE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS PANDEMIC FROM SO MANY
AMERICANS NOW GOING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, AS HE SAID.
BUT NOW TO THE FACT THAT GEE,
THIS IS A GUY WHO HELPED US WITH
THE RECOVERY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HELPED US WHEN
IT CAME TO DEALING WITH EBOLA,
THIS IS A GUY WHO KNOWS WHAT HE
IS DOING.
HE IS KNOWLEDGEABLE AND
EXPERIENCED AND READY FOR THE
JOB.
WITH REGARDS TO THIS, THIS IS
ABOUT SANDERS AND I THINK IT WAS
SANDERS P.R. PERSON WHO SAID I
AM NOT ENDORSING JOE BIDEN.
I CANNOT EVEN TELL YOU THE
WOMAN’S NAME, BUT IT IS A
UNIFIED DEMOCRATIC PARTY AT THIS
POINT AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS WHY DONALD TRUMP WAS
GOING TO THE UKRAINIANS.
HE DID NOT WANT TO FACE IT.
>> Jesse: I WOULD DISAGREE
ABOUT A STRONG ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, I WOULD ALSO DISAGREE
ABOUT A UNIFIED PARTY.
BUT GREG, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT IT ALL?
>> Greg: I HEARD WHEN JOE WAS
TOLD THAT HE GOT OBAMA’S
ENDORSEMENT, HE ALSO SAID, DID
HE WRITE FOR DEPOSIT ONLY?
NOBODY LIKED THAT JOKE.
I DON’T EVEN THINK I LIKED IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DID.
I LIKED IT.
>> Greg: I FIND IT AWESOMELY
IRONIC THAT JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT IN THE ERA OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
I MEAN, ISN’T THAT THE CRUELEST
PUNISHMENT YOU CAN PUT ON HIM?
THAT HE CAN’T TOUCH ANYBODY
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PERIOD.
YOU KNOW WHAT OBAMA IS LIKE,
REMEMBER WHEN YOUR TEACHER WOULD
MARCH YOU OVER TO ANOTHER
STUDENT AND GOAD YOU TO
APOLOGIZE, OR YOUR PARENTS
FORCED YOU TO INVITE THE KID YOU
DON’T LIKE TO YOUR BIRTHDAY
PARTY BECAUSE HIS MOTHER AND
YOUR MOTHER PLAY BRIDGE?
THAT IS OBAMA ENDORSING BIDEN,
HIS HEART IS NOT IN IT AT ALL.
HE FELT THAT HE HAD TO DO IT.
BECAUSE JOE, I DON’T BELIEVE
THAT JOE WAS THERE FOR
EVERYTHING.
JOE DOES NOT STRIKE ME AS SOME
DO YOU GO TO TO ASK FOR
PROFESSIONAL ADVICE.
HE IS A GUY AT WORK WHO IS
DRESSED VERY WELL AND HAS A NICE
WATCH.
ALWAYS AT EVERY HOLIDAY PARTY
WHEN THERE IS FREE PIZZA, BUT
NOBODY REALLY KNOWS WHAT HE
DOES.
AND HE LOVES TO WEAR THE BOMBER
JACKET AND THE AVIATOR
SUNGLASSES, HE LOVES THE EXPENSE
ACCOUNT.
HE LOVES BEING THAT GUY, BUT HE
IS NOT THE GUY THAT REALLY KNOWS
WHAT WAS GOING ON, AND HE NEVER
REALLY WANTED TO.
>> Judge Jeanine: CAN I SAY
ONE MORE THING BEFORE WE GO TO
BREAK, JESSE, THE THING THAT
INFURIATES ME IS THE ALLEGATIONS
OF, WHAT IS IT, TERRY REED?
THE WOMAN WHO CLAIMS THAT SHE
WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" COMING OUT
AND SAYING, WE HAVE NO OTHER
COMPLAINTS OF, THERE IS NO
PATTERN OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT,
THE GUYS SNIFFING EVERY WOMAN HE
EVER MET, GOING UP AND DOWN HER
BACK, HER HAIR, HER NECK, AND
THEY ARE SAYING HE IS THE
GREATEST THING SINCE SLICED
BREAD.
I MEAN, GREG, YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
SOCIAL DISTANCING WILL BE THE
BIGGEST PUNISHMENT HE COULD EVER
HAVE.
AND I AM DISGUSTED WITH THE
TIMES, AND ME TOO OUGHT TO GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER, IT APPLIES
TO THE DEMOCRATS TOO.
>> Jesse: YES, BIDEN RUNNING